Mike Florio from pro football talk he
always catches my attention because well
because he's mr. football he's got his
own show his own website have you heard
the news as the news gotten to you my
Super Bowl picks I have not heard your
Super Bowl patient lay them on me Mary
I've got the New Orleans Saints you want
to respond to that
I like that I've got the Saints going to
Green Bay in the NFC Championship game
but you know Lambeau Field frozen tundra
too much for a dome team to overcome but
but I was close to picking the picking
the Saints I got these San Diego
Chargers that ones that wolf
yeah that that'sthat's gutsy they're not
San Diego Chargers anymore yeah they are
okay yeah you know yes yes they're my
San Diego Chargers you can count on the
LA Chargers they're my San Diego
Chargers all right you caught my
attention because I saw your pics
earlier today with Chris Sims on Pro
Football Talk explain to me how you got
the Ravens going to the Superbowl well I
got the Ravens born of the Super Bowl
for a couple of reasons first of all the
defense is still very good I think their
offense is improved with the addition of
Michael Crabtree they really like John
Brown at receiver they just haven't had
receivers in recent years and Joe Flacco
has the ultimate fire under his butt
with the decision to draft Lamar Jackson
he's looked a lot better and this is a
team that even though they haven't been
good in recent years they've still been
in the mix you know 2016 the game in
Pittsburgh on Christmas Day that game
goes the other way it's not the Steelers
in the playoffs it's the Ravens so they
knock on the door every year and if they
get in there the one team in the AFC
that the Patriots don't want to mess
with and the way that that playoff tree
worked out the Ravens go to New England
and the Ravens beat New England just
because they they have a history of
playing New England tough in New England
and winning the last time they played
there in the postseason last time the
Ravens were in the postseason they had
14 point leads twice in that game and
ended up losing to New England so I just
believe that this year with a little
extra pressure on coach John Harbaugh a
lot of extra pressure on Joe Flacco a
defense that is still good an offense
that has upgraded I can see them winning
the division
and I can see them navigating that
playoff tree because John Harbaugh has
proven in the past that he knows how to
do it so I'm I'm not ready to write them
off and I think if anything they're
going to be one of those teams that you
know in hindsight we're gonna say we
should have seen that one coming I
always like to be able to say I saw it
coming instead of I should have seen it
coming I say I should have seen it
coming away too often so every once in a
while I try to get ahead of it you have
the Packers going to the Superbowl as
well the Bears are gonna be better I
don't the Lions will be stagnant and
then you've got the Vikings who may not
be as good as last year maybe they will
be but you still have them with
home-field advantage here which I find
interesting explain that well I think if
Aaron Rodgers stays healthy all year
which who knows we just assume he's
going to be fine he's had broken
collarbones derail seasons twice in the
last five years and unless he gets rid
of the ball a little bit more quickly
unless he's he's willing to not you know
and that's how he got hurt in that game
against Minnesota last year he held on
to the ball to give Martellus Bennett
more time to pop open so he could run 30
yards with it once he caught it and of
course he dropped it and Aaron Rodgers
breaks his collarbone but he's gonna
have to keep himself healthy but if he
stays healthy I like what they've done
defensively they hung on to Dom Capers
for way too long they finally got rid of
him
they brought in Mike Pettine who's going
to have that very aggressive Rex Ryan
style defense I think it gives the
players on the defensive side of the
ball a kick in the butt and and it's
going to be a better defense you add
Jimmy Graham to the mix and I think the
Packers gonna make full use of him
unlike what the Seahawks did I think
Rodgers is gonna find him in the red
zone regularly Graham is going to emerge
again as one of the best tight ends in
the game and I see the 1 seed in their
future either their early season
schedule is very easy and I think that
sets up for you know building the
confidence necessary to keep winning
winning winning the next thing you know
you're in the you're in the playoffs
you're hosting playoff games and there's
a the sense of urgency with the Packers
this year with the change in GM and I
think there's going to be a higher level
of accountability for coach Mike
McCarthy I have a feeling that this team
is finally going to fulfill the
potential that we've said since their
last Super Bowl appearance they've been
failing to live up to I don't know if
you realize this or May
you didn't realize it but you had
Seattle winning the NFC West yes I
really like Seattle I think we're all we
all were all a little bit asleep on
Seattle I think Russell Wilson is gonna
break through if he isn't there already
as one of the top two or three
quarterbacks in football this year he
did everything for that offense last
year and I think they had a much-needed
reset a hard reset after five straight
appearances in the playoffs five
straight final eight appearances they
missed the playoffs at nine and seven I
mean how many teams would love to be
nine and seven and they made some hard
decisions with the coaching staff with
the roster they've refocused they've
reconfigured but like every other team
that has a franchise quarterback they
understand the center of the universe is
the quarterback you build around it and
I think the Seahawks are going to be
good enough to overcome the 49ers who I
think we're too much in love with what
they did at the end of the season last
year and I just think the Rams have have
welcomed too much pressure and I could
see the Seahawks you know morphing into
that roll of the hunters for the first
time in a long time proving a lot of
people wrong winning games thanks to
Russell Wilson and just enough with
players that had been stuck on the bench
in the past because they had all these
high-priced big-name players they're
going to show if they've got other guys
who can step in and get it done if you
were lay beyond Bell's agent what would
you do now well I you know that is a
hell of a question I don't know what the
plan is I think what happened last week
when we saw odo Beckham jr. Aaron
Rodgers Aaron Donald Khalil Mack get
paid I think Khalil Mack was the
clincher I think that's what changed the
thinking from I'll show up and make 14.5
million to I'm going to try to do
something here to get more money in my
pocket the problem is he can't sign a
long-term deal right now with the
Steelers or anyone else the window on a
long-term deal opens after the regular
season ends and I I wonder whether or
not there's going to be an effort or
there already is an effort to instigate
a trade to a team that would take on lay
beyond Bell now give this dealer
something in return for a guy that maybe
the locker room doesn't currently want
after everything that happened yesterday
and then as part of that transaction
there's some linking there some nodding
and there's an understanding that come
the Monday after week 17 Nats when lady
on Bell is going to get 15 million 17
million whatever the number is but when
you look at what the Bears gave up to
get Khalil Mack twenty three and a half
million per year in new money Plus picks
right those picks have value
the Browns paid 16 million for a
second-round pick last year so how much
more would they have given Khalil Mack
on the open market you know what is his
lay beyond bail worth and I think he
sees that money that's been thrown
around to other great players and I
think he's now determined to try to get
it the problem is it's it's going to be
very difficult to get the Steelers to do
anything they aren't inclined to rescind
a franchise tag maybe they'd be inclined
to trade him if there's someone out
there that would trade for him and have
that behind the scenes unenforceable
promise that here's what you're going to
get once the season ends that may be the
end game here but I can't reconcile the
agent saying in one breath yesterday
where were leery of the Steelers using
him too much with in the next breath he
still intends to have his best
statistical season of his career how do
you the only way that that happens is if
he gets traded to a team that is giving
him security even if it comes after the
season or if he gets that kind of a
promise from the Steelers you know they
could do a wink nod with him hey come
back
weekly here's what we will put on the
table for you right after the season
ends but I think he wants something more
than 14.5 four million this year it's
just gonna be hard to get it have fun
tonight Mike with the season opener tell
the boys that I said alone all right
thank you buddy
that's Mike Florio join us brought to
you by the 2018 Mercedes AMG e-class
suite of innovative technologies one of
the most intelligent cars on the road go
to you MBUSA comm or visit local
dealership to schedule your test drive
today for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you